friendly gestures and warm words when
Barack Obama came to Berlin in June
transatlantic ties still seem to be in
order now the German newspaper Bild on
Sontag is reporting the president
allowed US intelligence to eavesdrop on
Chancellor Angela Merkel just weeks
earlier the newspaper also quoted German
Interior Minister Hans bethe freely
saying if the Americans have tapped
mobile phones in Germany they have
broken German law on German soil
eavesdropping is a criminal offence and
those responsible must be held
accountable president obama is said to
have assured Chancellor Merkel he knew
nothing about the eavesdropping
operation but intelligence sources told
the build on Sontag he was informed
about the program in 2010 and didn't
stop it as he had said instead the
president asked for more detailed
information about the German Chancellor
demonstrations in front of the US
Capitol called for an end to pervasive
surveillance and the alleged tapping of
Angela Merkel's telephone was on
everyone's lips we have the National
Security Agency hacking into the cell
phone Angela Merkel that is completely
duit arias to to our relationship with
our own allies these demonstrators say
Americans should realize the spy scandal
affects everyone and hope more people
will join them